Well. Well, well go to your mom's house
Christina. Please sit. Sit.
Yeah. Crazy people. Raise your children.
Yeah, you're right. Um, you got it. You
get cool. You got to raise your kids,
you got to raise your kids. I
know. Are you being facetious? No,
I just think it's um, a silly
thing to have to say, you know.
Well I think for the super wealthy,
the super rich,
he don't have time to be
with their children and then
they pushed them off onto
nannies. Yeah. It's like,
I mean I get why, but ah,
cause then that motherfucker
raises your kids. Yeah, sure.
We know who's raising your kids.
Who was raising your kid and they're not
kissing him all day and loving on him
like you are.
I got three beverages.
I got a d c I got to Lukla and then
of course water cause the champion.
Where's your water? Yeah, I'm
actually really thirsty. Really? Yeah.
I'm thirsty right now,
Kevin.
Probably because you haven't been
hydrating. Yeah. At all today.
I haven't seen you drink any water.
I drank a bunch.
I bought a couple of waters actually,
I was out. I get thirsty. Sorry.
This is your name on here? No,
it's not main mommy water champion.
Who this belongs to.
I can sell you it.
Okay, cool. Could you
drag it out more? Thanks.
Yeah, I can't because if the
audience is paying attention,
they can see that I'm the water champion.
Oh,
and you had to beg me for my water
because I hydrate constantly.
Mm hmm.
Oh,
why are you so sweaty right now? Cause
I was running around. I ran outside,
I switched the boards,
having board problems.
I finally installed the new sound craft
board and it was recommended to me.
I couldn't get it to, uh, to
function. I couldn't get it to work.
I did it really quick. That's why I
did it really quick. I know, I know.
I didn't take my time with it, but fuck
man, I could not get, I couldn't get the,
uh,
this is boring to people,
but I couldn't get this to
read the sound through the USB.
I couldn't get it to work.
USB It,
you play it into it.
This is a,
this was sent in by somebody
named first name, last name,
what's called the higher titer
show opener. I like it to go ahead.
Oh well at this point,
um, the time this airs,
I will be at the Dcm prob
December 9th and 10th.
And then I'm home. We got a busy couple
months coming up. Jeans wearing, moving.
Jesus cry. It's so much shit. But
you are your hustling like Rick Ross.
I'm on the road constantly.
I know. Not only that,
I just announced a tour that uh,
that starts in January. You'll see
Ellis when he's five. Oh stop it. Ah,
but you gotta go cause
we got to pay that more.
That's an official adult status. Now I
know you're not going out to do shows.
You're like, I got paid for sure. The
pay the mortgage tour. Well you can,
I drop some knowledge and yeah. So
you mentioned you're, you're doing,
you have one one day.
This week I'm in,
I'm in Jude or titties. Um, by the way,
you can get free tickets to see
my unmask with uh, Ron Bennington.
Yes.
That's going to be Thursday.
If you go to Bennington show
at Bennington show on Twitter,
you can get free tickets
from them to that.
That's going to be Thursday at 3:00 PM.
And then I have shows all weekends.
I Caroline's um,
coming up after that.
Lou Louiseville Kentucky in Lewisville.
Loserville uh,
crawling me North Carolina. I'm at
a good night's Charlie. Good Nights.
Yeah. And then I rounded
out. I do fill her up.
Delphia the truck.
There's going to be the Ka Cadera theater.
That's good.
Got It.
And fill her up who's four
shows and in December,
west balls, beach, Florida. And
I'm doing new year's in mom.
Lando. Oh, that should be fun. Yeah.
Then I know I announced a big
tour that starts in January.
It's all at Thomson [inaudible] Dot
Com and there's even some dates not
mentioned there. They're going to
be added. For instance, Oxnard is,
is right before that official tour starts.
Um,
and there's other cities that
I'm going to add during the year,
but it's all on sale now.
So loud.
Where can they go get your tickets?
Thompson Jr com [inaudible] dot com guys,
uh,
also checkout. That's deep, Bro. Pied
Cass. I just had Kevin Christie on,
we, uh, talk about grief. It's real fun
actually. It ended up being a really fun,
fine cast and we laughed a lot
and we were really happy. It was,
it really was grief.
Yeah.
Cause his dad died in a horribly bizarre
11 accident that was really like a
horrible hiking accident.
And then my mom died last year and we
talked about it and ended up paying like
super, not a bummer. I know it
sounds like bummer, but it was in,
this was if I recall, um,
uncircumcised men. Yeah.
Uncircumcised.
You sound like that guy has in recall
in circumstances guys and Co no,
what I was going to say is that,
uh,
I remember that his dad was like
an experienced guy. Yeah. Right.
You knew the terrain
very, very well. Yeah.
And then the storm came and then no good.
They never found them horrendous.
Yeah.
So how does he deal with
something like that?
And I think it's a valuable lesson and
people dealing with all kinds of crap.
Like grief is not just a death that people
lose stuff you lose every day. Right?
You win some,
you lose some guys.
That's how it's always been ups and
downs and we get super deep on it.
Um,
yeah,
the holidays are coming
up and what the holidays.
You got to start doing your Amazon on
shopping. Am I right? Absolutely.
I advise you to buy your gifts
on Amazon using our banner.
Go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the
bottom of the homepage.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
Buy a your Halloween costumes by your
Christmas gifts and have them shipped to
the people that you're going to go visit.
Don't travel with a bag full of gifts.
You think Tsa is going to respect
your nicely? Rats present.
Hell no to the no, no.
I'm not Tsa. I don't give
a fuck. They'll fuck up your
shit man. How'd they should say?
You know what I'm saying? You know what
I'm saying? You know what I'm saying?
Shit. Shit. Shit.
Why not get a the the loved one in your
life. A gift from your mom's house.
Why not go to our shop
on your mom's house,
podcast.com and buy a tee shirt,
DG dad mal shirt.
Get a double five classic shirt.
We might be coming out with one soon.
We're going to reveal later for the
special holidays. It's going to be major
thoughts. Oh my God,
that dress is everything.
Do you guys know who that is?
That's Rachel's though.
We used to watch that show
together and she was so ridiculous.
Was like, oh my God,
that dress is everything.
She talks a lot of vocal fry
is really the most, yeah.
I remember looking for clips of her
though years ago. It was hard to find now.
She said, well she's on, I
follow her on Instagram. Um,
but I don't know are the clips every day.
She's like,
I just woke up and I
don't have any makeup on.
And then I got up and her face is fully
botoxed like she's, she looks great.
I think it's great for her age. She's
almost my you want to start the show?
Yeah.
Madge actually it's a clip from one
of your boyfriends from college.
It is. I have it muted. Oh,
he looks familiar though.
That was my freshman year.
That's when I was still doing white guys.
This is your boy.
We have your permission and everything
to do like use all this footage of you
and stuff and put it online.
Fuck yeah.
Even all that IFQ stuff.
And if you're not cool with it,
I mean the stuff that you were
talking about, like that'd
be close. Shit. Fuck it.
A chef a goddamn thing. I'm
not, I ain't gonna lie to you.
Just want to make sure that you're
cool then. Fuck it. Throw it back on.
Are we good with this?
Okay.
Oh, it's Ryan. Don't
bring in one 11 to this.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Stretching.
Uh, yeah. Um, so do you remember
dating this guy or no? Well,
we didn't date, but we,
we just asked. Oh really?
This is my last white boyfriend before
I started dating a lot of Puerto Rican
dudes. Um, and then I married you. Wow.
That was like five Puerto Rican dudes.
That's really something.
But he was special because this guy was
a math major and he would occasionally
smoke crack. Like he would pick it
up one month stop. Yeah. You know,
he was real smart.
Do you miss him all the time?
Is that Derek? I Miss Derek. Derek. Yeah.
That looks like a Derek doesn't it does,
it does matter or uh, uh, Rick? Uh,
I could see a Rick Scott. Yeah.
Scott. I've known really trashy.
Scott's too. Yeah, I've done quite a few.
Yeah. Why is Scott such a trash name?
Have a no, we're going to get some Skype
messages for sure. Many Scott. Matt. Hey,
what's up Scott? Fucking
pieces of shit. I'm closing
everyone. I did that at
that, at the Burbank show.
Were you there for that?
You were there.
I remember we were doing the meet
and greet and this girl was like, oh,
well you say hi to like my friend Derek
and I go, yeah. And I always like,
I don't know how to
make it. Yeah, not lame.
So I just go to dumb and I go,
what's up Derek?
You fucking
piece of shit. Oh, right. Yeah. She
was like, her face dropped. Yeah.
Um, okay. I got like
really offended by it.
I go, how could you get, I don't
know. You read a comedy show.
What would you get offended by that?
But what was the, I thought he was like
five years old or something. No. Oh,
what if he was like a five
year old kid and you're like,
Derek's a fucking piece of shit. Be Like
you fucking Jew. And she was like, he is.
I remember I go, I just
guessed that I, no,
I block out stupid moments like
that in my life. Yeah. Yeah.
I just block them right out.
I can't think about it. Okay.
No, I'm serious. Like stupidity that
she was being stupid. Yeah. I like,
I don't even as as as a register anymore.
Yeah. I'm upset about this board.
What's wrong? What do you mean? What's
wrong about this particular board?
We're both getting the other
board in here. Well, I mean, look,
you knew that that was going to be a
time investment to I didn't think so. Oh,
I think it takes, I just throw these
things out in the same, same compartments,
you know, same inputs, but
it's a different board. I know,
but I didn't think it would be that
complicated. Yeah. Yeah. Well, okay,
this sounds good.
I mean it's still good.
All right.
Um, well, uh, what do you, you don't
want me to be upset about it? No, I mean,
I don't know.
It's,
I think you've done a great job is what
I'm trying to validate you and you say
that we carried on and it's
good man. Yeah, I guess so.
All right, fine. Yeah.
Well what is my boyfriend talking
about? I have no idea. I have no idea.
It says deckhands. Yeah, I think it's
a show. This is a reality show. Okay.
And these guys are a Mensa members.
Yeah.
Why hasn't this mentioned in
here that what it is though?
Like why isn't it mentioned in the
description and I don't know. Do you have,
do you know what it's from deck
hands. What's that? I Dunno.
Okay. Just deck hands. Who are
you mad? Are you mad at blue band?
She didn't put on there. Of
course. Oh, okay. Why? What,
what is this supposed to be?
From what?
I don't know. Bam. Okay.
The only person I ever have to lie to
is the God damn judge fucking line.
She fucking rich pieces.
That shit fucking getting richer off the
fucking was there breaking her hands.
Fuck you mother fuckers. That's what
I got to say about the whole life.
Do you think fuck down?
I F whew. Yeah, no idea.
Okay.
Um,
Ifq so you don't remember this guy?
You don't remember making love to him?
No, I'm telling you, he was my last
white boyfriend freshman year, Derek.
Yeah. And he came from,
um, Medford, Oregon,
which is like a logger town. He's
real, you know, rough around the edges,
but that's why I liked him.
His hands were kind of rough,
but he was soft inside and you know.
Yeah.
I love guys like that. Do
you, Chris is a little bit,
but I just didn't introduce him to my
parents. Do you remember lovemaking?
He's very gentle.
Yeah.
You'd be surprised how sweet
Derek's lovemaking is. What,
um, what about it is a real treat? Well,
a lot of his breath smelled bad
like whiskey or marijuana, mo,
one cigarette.
But when he wasn't high or drunk,
uh,
he was real sweet. Those are the best,
um, like votes of confidence on people,
you know, when they're not fucked up,
they're awesome. Yeah. That's the best.
He enjoying the, he does no one, you know,
and when he gets on those things,
he's a different guy
on a whiskey.
He gets cozy.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah. It's kind of a bummer to only
have like half a person in your life,
you know? Like I always am amazed when
women hang in there for those types of
relationships. Like, well, you know,
I mean, 70% of the time he's a pls,
but then that 30, this really is an
example. I mean, she's a little slow.
I don't know if you can really buy the,
wait a minute. Yeah. What are you saying?
She's a little, not on the level.
Like why, like how are you can,
you can hear it and you're gonna hear it.
She's not, she's not doing so so well.
She is a retard.
Yeah.
Do you ever seen old Mcdonald had a farm?
When you start making the fuck
it insect sounds back there.
No net farm. He had a break.
Great. Great. Very what?
What'd you start thinking of that
crazy shit. That's what good.
I'd rather listen to
some fucking Metallica or
something while you're killing
shit. Right. You know
he always liked Metallica.
What is he saying?
That he'd rather listen to Metallica
than old Mcdonald had a farm.
Yeah, but it wears on me down all the
head of farm playing. Why you don't know,
but I also don't know how you find
a sun visor with a rebel flag. Oh,
I know where you can get one.
You ever seen old Mcdonald had a farm?
Ever see when you start making the
fucking insect sounds back there
knowing that farm, he had a
great, great, great, great, great.
What do you start thinking that crazy
shit man. I'd rather listen to buffer.
Yeah, these are winter shoes. He'll do
that down the fucking 60 this morning.
Oh my God.
About race.
Nice. He Drinking Busch
lite. Maybe that's also,
you see that like in Florida you
see it's a real winner circle.
Yup. Yup. Busch light.
Cause that's like a 12 or for like six
bucks or something. And that's real cheap.
Real cheap. Yeah. It's like 50
cents a beer man. That's like man,
when you're in high school and you're in
Florida and you're drinking out in the
groves and a,
and also when you're a deck deckhand
or you wear a confederate flag visor,
you drink Busch lite.
So is a show that follows this piece
of shit around here. He said, why not?
If you're gonna Invest in alcohol,
how much could that 12 or be like,
am I just getting night or thunder bird?
Yeah, it's stronger. And number two,
if you're going to wear socks,
why mash the flip flop into the
sock in between the two doing,
he's thinking these things
through. You think he's like, hmm,
I don't know if this really adds up to me.
He probably doesn't do that.
Why not just commit to a
full close toed situation?
We found a boat, but it was
60 in the morning. He said,
oh this is the winter time he's got colon.
Do you think he has cute Tutsis are now.
Oh, they're super nice. Yeah. All right.
Yeah
he does. I've seen her.
Oh my God. Dot Com.
Yeah.
My Dad's toenails are fully yellow
and like corroded and falling off.
It's been not only for years.
You know why that happens though?
You know why they're at this level.
Cause he's never at the early level.
Didn't care.
That's what,
that's how all shit gets like that
winning when it started he was like,
I'll give a fuck.
Well let's,
maybe it will just go away on its
own and you ignore it. I tell you,
the older I get, the less I ignore
body stuff now. Cause you're like,
this could be cancer.
Like everything could be potentially bad.
Like really bad at my
age. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
It can be an indicator
of like severe problems.
Do you think he's eating
like a Kale? I, by the way,
I think about that all the time.
Everything could be a problem.
I started thinking about it much
more people our age die now. I know,
and I just had a physical, we've got,
we'll get into that. That's a whole,
that's a whole episode. Yeah. But I
mean, I mean, do you want to go there?
You want to hear what Heidegger,
Nietzsche has to say here?
Aristotle, Aristotle of
Florida. What's this guy up to?
What's he eating?
Hi,
my name is Shane.
Mother fucking league.com
www.com fuck yet.
Dot Com.
Fuck yeah.
This is a show where they're just
following a bum, like a drunk,
a drunk drifter in Florida
around is what it feels like.
How go Florida attracts like this specific
type of trash because you can survive
there. I think you're never going
to freeze to death, you know? Um,
you could get work doing bullshit,
right?
Being a decade working in the
orange groves or you don't,
you don't have to like
have a high Falutin job.
You can sneak and sleep outside and by
Busch light and you can just drink it and
just go to work. He was working.
He was being, he was on the boat.
Do you think it's like,
it's the swamp thing? Like,
you know how there's either
swamp people. Yeah. I Dunno man.
There are a swamp people. I mean, I think
there's a combination of everything.
I it's that,
that um, you know, it's an easy yes.
Easy state to carry a weapon in. There
you go. There's no state income tax.
Yup. That draws in people that are really
rich. And then people who were like,
I don't pay no motherfucking taxes.
So, uh, you know, I don't know.
I think the combination of those and that,
and you can wear a confederate flag sun
visor and nobody gives you a static.
Yeah. That's also what is another way
I wear them. Yeah. Yeah. In Florida,
um, nobody's going to look twice
at you, right? I'm Marna. Yeah.
Got It. That's a scary part. In
some parts of Florida, nobody will,
some places they won't give a double
take. Yeah, that's true. I mean,
you can't do that Shit in Miami.
Yeah, I know, but be like Boca, but,
well, good. I got the tools to
show you a fog of wings of plugin.
Very fucking bag of fucking fighter.
I'm not bagging,
but
look at him.
He's just a drunk though.
Yeah. I actually just,
I want to punch the production people
for showcasing what are you doing? Yeah.
This guy's a fucking idiot.
Because the key to an interesting,
crazy is that they're interesting.
Yeah. I need to have something else.
Just some fucking loser being
a loser. Yeah. Like, Hey,
you want to follow a loser
around with a camera?
Like a guy that just never leaves the
front of seven 11 and let's give them a
show.
That show should just be called losers
and they go to seven 11 and silver lake.
Remember we used to live. Yeah,
that one. Next warehouse. Right.
Follow people buying hot dogs.
Not Evil. We're not evil people.
Right?
Yeah.
Who Was it? Was it Jeff Tate
that was buying all the hot
dogs, dogs and Gatorade.
Right. But there's someone else that we
would have. Did he message you by the way?
Uh, no he didn't. I don't think
so. Messaged me on the twitters.
No text message you, I don't know. All
right, cool. No, it's good. Busy Day.
That was really in there. I wish the
Persian lady would start texting me. Yeah.
That will be the best.
You know,
I got a message for Shenaz today in
other nursing opportunity in Florida.
Oh really? Uh Huh. She's missed out on
a ton of them. I have to tell you this.
I cannot believe I, you know, when you
don't write shit down, you fuck yourself.
Right.
Uh,
this happened when I was back in
Charlotte, in Charlotte, North Carolina.
I went to, I was doing the show.
You're not going to believe this.
I have to actually show you,
set this up so you,
you know exactly what I'm talking about.
Okay.
This is a perfect timing.
This is the infamous bikes
clip that ended up being a bit,
right.
So this is the kid.
Did I talk about in this that I didn't
even notice that before I talk about his
and the special
talking about this whole
exchange. Yeah. So this guy,
sorry.
Right, right. It's horrible
audio. But that's the kid. Okay.
That's him. I'm sitting
there, I'm not sitting there.
I'm standing on stage and performing
in Charlotte on Friday, I think.
Friday, early show. Really? Really?
I still remember it. You know, you,
you forget about shows.
It was such a good show.
It's such a good crowd during the show.
He's laying in the front row.
I say something, I go,
what? And she goes, I dated
this kid. No Shit. That's incredible.
It's very random. And so she dated
him at this age. You're kidding.
And I go, you have got to be
shitting me. She goes, no, I go.
So when you were dating like did this air,
she was like yeah.
And he ended up changing his name has,
his name is Tom Cigarette and I
ended up changing his name. Um,
uh, and anyways, now I,
well he did change his name cause then
you made this into a major bit. I know.
And then this guy's like,
what the fuck?
Um, but this is, this is
what I wanted to show you.
Well first of all,
I wanted to tell you that he is now,
now just went to prison.
No, it didn't really work. They
didn't scare him out of it.
I didn't scare them straight for
sure. I get it. Um, that never works.
Yeah.
You know,
like in Springer when they bring out the
teenagers that were rebelling and then
they'd yell at them.
Yeah, it doesn't work.
Do you want to see what it looks
like now or not? Love to see what it,
so look at him here. Well how would you
describe those? Adorable. He's like,
this kid can be our son. Yeah.
He looks really cute. Just
perfect little area. Boy.
It was like a sweet kid, right? Yeah.
But the haircuts menacing but you know,
menacing well to Hitler
youth. Come on, he's got,
he's got a bowl cut.
Parted in the middle.
It looks like he looks
like hey hiller okay. Um,
that him well if that's what
the says he's a Daikin. Oh no,
that's him now. Okay. That's crazy. Yeah.
And how did you find this picture?
Cause I found out his name from the lady.
Um,
Justin.
That I think that's a hand.
Yeah.
Come job stoppers there.
Yup. But look at that. Uh,
he's doing the grimace,
but you know what though?
The kid that got yelled at and secure.
This is what you'd expect for the
ghost of Christmas future for this kid,
you know, or you expect that fucking
accountant scared me straight.
I don't know. Wow. That's so crazy. Genes.
Do you think he knows the backend?
Can't believe you don't think this is a
bigger deal? Um, I don't only because,
only because in this era of the
Internet now, yeah, it's everything.
Everything comes together so much faster.
Yeah.
I'm serious that a woman probably
was like, oh my gosh. She's like,
she's probably a fan of yours. And
then she put it. Yeah. You know,
it's not that crazy. Now
you have lots of fans. Okay.
Well I thought it was pretty crazy.
And um,
she also let me know his
mailing address in prison. Um,
now that's crazy. You're
going to write to, that part's
crazy. If you write to him.
Well,
I was thinking of giving out his address
so that everyone could write to him. Um,
I sure will.
And to encourage him to be not a
criminal or just get through your time.
You know how many fucking dumb shit he's
going to get or people are like, bikes.
It's all, it's going to be his bikes.
I know. Pull your jeans up, Justin,
stay in, stay out of
prison. I was like, wait,
why are these people calling me mommy
bikes and the drawing pictures of bikes?
That's what I wanted is that
he just opened the letter
and it just has a drawing
of a bite. Do you want
to help? I don't know.
I mean I asked and then I consulted with
somebody legally about doing that and
they said it was fine because you know,
we're asking people to
write something nice.
I'm just apprehensive about it.
I'm apprehensive to intuitively,
it doesn't sound like a
good idea. Yeah. I mean,
look what happens when people just, we
set the mommy's on like a Twitter person.
We got Gloria,
Stefan on Gloria.
Stefan because of the
mommies. Yeah. I don't know.
We might ruin that guy. I don't want to
do that. I really don't want to do that.
It wasn't, I mean, I really
thought it'd be cool in my mind.
The cool thing would be he goes,
uh, he's in prison would suck,
which sucks. Then they go like, hey mail.
And like one guy gets a letter,
one guy gets two letters and they
hid the guy's first name is Justin.
I can say that you Justin. And they have
to just like a bundle and what the fuck.
And then people are writing
cool things to him. Like, yeah,
like you'll get through this or you know,
encouraging stuff. Um, you know the guy,
I think he's, I don't know if he's
married, he's got a couple of kids.
I don't know. They could, people
could be cool. But then again,
if people would just go
off and do some crazy,
I don't want to be the
one who encouraged you,
who they blame for inciting that,
you know?
Yeah. I don't know. So
anyways, let's think about it.
Let's talk to our lawyer.
Okay, let's ask our attorney.
I'll say this, it's not
that hard to find. Okay.
So I'll just say that it's not that
hard to find him. No. Oh, I mean,
if you know me and you can find me.
Okay.
And your finance availed. Okay.
Like where could they find you?
On Twitter or, I dunno, there's
other places. I don't know.
I can't come on. You can't solve
the whole mystery? No. Okay.
So they see you on social media.
Maybe they can find this place to
send Justin some nice mail I guess.
I think they could, I'm not
telling you you can. Okay.
But I would encourage you, if you do
decide to ride Justin a letter. I mean,
seriously say something nice.
Wouldn't that be,
wouldn't if it sucked for like
wouldn't it suck? First of all,
they told me that his vibe,
like his crime was that he,
I think he was on probation and he was in,
um,
in possession of stolen property.
So it's very possible that why
he's in prison is because of like,
he could have received a stolen
and ends up in prison. So anyways,
what I'm saying is that
sucks just to go to prison.
Wouldn't it be cool if at least you get
like a hundred letters or more work?
Definitely.
That'd be the bright spot in your day.
And that's the part of me that
wants to do it, but I like, again,
a mystery that he would never,
maybe so like,
yeah. What's Netflix like? I don't know
how long he's been away. What's Netflix?
He just went away now. Oh, okay. Yeah,
no, he just, he just got locked up.
That is so bananas.
And she told me about it at the show
and I wrote to her later like, you know,
just asking questions and
stuff and you know, Nice Kid,
12 year old kid. She was there with her
husband. Probably came from a bad family.
I'm guessing Justin didn't
have great parents maybe.
I'm guessing you didn't have a lot
of guidance, do you think so? Yeah.
And that's why you're
in the shit at 12 year.
You're on the scared straight show because
the parents don't give a fuck about
you. You're running the
streets. Yeah. Seriously.
You're not even capable of shit unless
your parents are bad. It's true.
Yeah. You tired hun jeans. You
had a long day. It was a long day.
Do you want to talk about the
physical? I think we should. Okay.
I have some of that. Which one is that?
One of my three. It's so it's also not,
it's not even open yet. Sweet.
Oh, it's nice and cold. Yeah. Um,
yeah. So here's what happened man.
It's been two years. Why not? Yeah,
it's been two years since my last
physical. I like to stay on top of it.
And Yours is, how long has your, I forgot,
cause you told me years
has been how many years? 40
I can't believe you've never had one.
I've never had a physical. You know why?
Because I'm Hungarian. I got
cockroach. DNA. It's true. It is true.
I have no problems.
I don't believe in this fucking bullshit.
You by 25 to 45
Jesus.
I hope so. I don't want
you to die. Thanks.
Your genetics are far weaker than
mine. Yeah, you're less resilient.
You get sicker more.
Yup.
He is sick more that your bowels
are constantly bothering you.
All right, so here's what happened. Yeah.
I go in first of all,
from 2014 I weigh,
I weigh 10 pounds less than I did in
2014. Good. That's good. Check. Oh wait,
22 pounds less than I did
about six weeks ago. Okay.
That's when I started eating like
Kido Kedo yeah, he does hardware,
Quito, Quito, c. K. E. T.
O. Yeah. Okay. That's cute.
Even after Quito, Kaylyn, it's the
mantra. Quito. Kaitlin. And uh,
so that's the good stuff. That's best.
Best about what good stuff ends. So,
so then he goes by doctors real thorough.
He is doctor Dick by the way.
Yes.
If you follow my standup at all.
Completely normal or you
stream it on Pandora, I get a,
a breakdown.
The charts top tracks that are streaming
and doctor Dick has been number one for
me for about, I dunno, 15 months.
He Israel,
he's our doctor.
I go see this guy too and he says
horrendously funny shit to us. So
that's the guy. Anyways, he keeps a
really thorough notes, really thorough,
you know, back ground stuff.
So he's like, you know, yeah.
Your waist down.
Let me see what I wrote down
2014 you guys lose weight.
Yes. You fucking finally listened
to me. I go, all right, man.
Keeps talking. Asking
me. You know how things,
anything bothering you. He goes, Oh yeah,
I wrote that you had food poisoning this
one time, you had this. I said, yeah,
you know, I, um, oh, I had to,
I had a food allergy test and they sent
it to him cause they send any specialist
sends something to him. He goes, that
came back all negative. I said, yeah,
I'm going to see this
gastroenterologist though.
I had a consultation just because of
like explosive diarrhea and crazy shirts
and shit.
And he said,
and I broke down for him how
there's kind of no rhyme or reason.
Like some days it's horrible.
Yeah.
It's also like quick and then
some days it's fine, it's IBS.
Anyways, he goes, hmm, hmm.
Uh, and then has, has, have you had
that test or that test? And I go, uh,
no, I'm having, I'm having it coming up.
And he goes, yeah, I think you should.
And he goes, shit, I test.
Should I check your prostate?
And I go, uh, he goes, it looks
at me and I go, I don't know,
like you're the doctor because
we were a little young for it.
I don't think so. All right. Let
me keep talking about gastro stuff.
He goes, but maybe there's
something there. Hm.
All right. Uh, all right,
we'll do it. And I'm like,
oh man. And were you bond cause it
sounded like you got out of it. Yeah.
Well I wasn't bummed cause I told
him I go, he kept looking at me like,
what do you want to do? And I
go, dude, I, I trust your right.
If you think it do it,
do it.
But have you ever had a finger
in your butt hole? Yes. Okay.
But not that deep. So lemme tell
you about this saying is that it's,
it's his, if someone told me
we're not going to do this
today, I'd be like, great,
let's move on. Yeah. I wouldn't
debate it. Quit debating it in,
they don't put it in there cause
I don't like a finger in my butt.
So anyways, we do the physical. Oh.
Then he goes, oh, let's
run a quick EKG on you.
And I'm like, all right. He runs it.
And as is has been the case,
I have a super low,
uh, sitting heart rate. No. Like, uh,
like an athlete. Yeah. Which is again,
it's in that, it's in that bit,
it's all like jokes about that.
So he goes and your heart rate is so long
ago. I know. It hasn't changed though.
It's always been like that. He
goes, I want you to wear a monitor,
a heart monitor at home tonight
while you sleep. I'm like,
why? He goes, because I want to see how
low it gets when you're sleeping. He goes,
if it gets this slow when you're awake.
Yeah.
I want to see how low it gets when
you're sleeping. And I'm like, God damn.
We probably have near death experiences
every night you think are dreams or on
the other side.
And if you don't know,
you know the jokes that
I make about at our,
because marathon runners really,
really strong cardiovascular people,
their hearts are strong,
so therefore they,
they don't beat as many times per minute.
So I have a, my heart, my
sitting heart rate's around 44.
There's gotta be like a hole in it or
something that's making it extra slow.
Well it's definitely not,
I'm laid back.
Maybe he goes like, are you ever
tired? And I'm like all the time. Yeah.
That's your heart.
So anyways,
I wore that.
I slept last night like a 90 year old man.
15 patches. Oh, it's embarrassing. And
I mean it was fine. I don't bad for you.
I saw people look at it. When I
went from him, I went to the, uh,
rite aid. I had a button down. Yeah.
Like this one. People were like,
this guy's about to die. I'm surprised
I didn't shave your chest though.
Cause it didn't it. Yes. Did it, did heres
rip out multiple hundreds possibly. Yeah.
They usually shave you for that.
They didn't know.
How did you sleep with that stupid thing
in your pocket? It was, I had shorts
on and I was honestly what, you know
what helped yesterday I was so tired.
Does it was easy to fall asleep,
been a rough couple of week in a cigarette
house. We're recording this at night.
When I a while the baby sleeps.
We normally do this in a day,
but it's been naughty. Yeah.
Yeah. Lots going on. So,
okay. He fingers your but wait, no, no,
no. We're not there yet. Oh, I'm sorry.
They take a bunch of blood.
Yeah,
I do a urine test. He goes, I'm here.
You're going to take this heart
thing at home. I go, okay.
Then he checks the balls,
you know.
And what does that feel like? Is it kind
of Nice or it's a medical, it's medical.
It's real medical.
He touch it.
Hard to feel for lumps
are not hard pressure.
It's,
it's soft to medium,
but he checks it. Does he wear gloves or
free ball and free. Free hands. Gloves.
A soft, nice hands. Nice hands.
Yeah. And you can tell him
knows what to do with a pair and nuts.
Like he knows how to hold them medically.
Sure. Um, yeah. So do you
have to cough? Is that real?
Sometimes I didn't have to coffee
yesterday, but I have had to cough before.
Why do they do that?
Um,
I guess because they know like it's a
reflex thing to seem to live close to go.
So if they don't, maybe something's
wrong. I Dunno. Hmm. Um, anyways,
checked me all out, then comes in and he
goes, all right, lay on your left side.
Hmm.
Yeah.
And he goes in there
now with your left hand.
So imagine you're laying
on your left side. Yeah.
Extend your hand as far as you can
and hold up your cell phone. I'm like,
okay. He's like an open the camera.
And I'm like, all right. He's like,
not put the reverse camp,
you know,
reverse camera on so you can, it's
up for a selfie. And I'm like, what?
And he's like, do it if I
put it on. And he's like, all
right, great. Take a picture.
I go, okay. So it's me holding it out.
And then he holds his finger up to his
nose and he's like, Ooh, like that.
That's what my doctor did. And I go,
can I please post this? He was like,
absolutely not.
I sent it to you though.
I was amazed. I really appreciate, I
can't post it. You know what I mean?
Now he's a professional. Yeah, he's
really good doctor. He's so thorough.
He's so good. He's a genius. That guy.
I go in there for like minor
stuff and he's so thorough.
Hey this so then comes the moment
truth. He's like lay, lay there.
Pull your knees up.
Yeah, we had been there and
he lubes up the finger. Right.
How much of the finger does he lubricate?
I can't really tell, but it feels,
and is it embedded in the middle?
He does,
um,
for the index and it's pretty low.
I asked him right before I go,
you want me to clean up back there?
And he kind of smiled and then
he's nice.
He's saying is that,
I thought of that with you because
that's my fear about putting my finger or
mouth on your rectum is
dirty. It must be. It was.
And the thing is is that it wasn't,
was it sweaty?
It was hot today in La. No, it was
yesterday. Oh is he? Yes. Yesterday.
Yeah, she was overcast. So you did,
but you did feel self conscious
about the smell. At first,
I didn't know even know
what it looked like.
So I real quick did a
cursory check back there.
I took some paper and I checked
you got nothing. So I was clean.
Yeah. Cause when I go to the
gynecologist I make sure I'm very clean.
I take a nice full, I didn't know anyone
was going to get in there. I knew,
I remember I asked you, yeah, I go, he's
going to stick his finger in your butt.
And you got no,
he's not because he wasn't going to,
he decided in the moment I asked
for it to not ask for it. So, uh,
he stick,
he sticks his finger in and I'm
surprised at the ease and also the,
uh, lack of discomfort I'm
feeling really at first.
Right. So it's like, okay. And
I'm like, oh, oh baby monitor.
I'm like, all right, that's not bad. Yeah.
And as that thought is processing,
like that's not bad.
He does a swipe. He goes, he
goes, no polyps like that.
And then he goes, oh, I can feel it. He
goes check into profit. And I'm like,
I do like the like just startled,
you know, like absolutely. Ah,
ah. And he goes, you want
a second opinion? I can put
another finger in there.
And I'm like, Dude. And then he pulls
it out. It goes, there you go. I'm like,
oh my God, man. Like it, it was
traumatic. It was traumatic.
It's terrible. Whenever someone puts
their hand inside of you, everyone,
I was getting checked when I was going
to birth Ellis and someone put their hand
at my coach every hour. Like it
hurts at that point. Terrible.
So he said,
now I put my finger like this and you
before it feels like I have to shit
immediately. You've
liked it. You liked it.
It feels like I have to shit now.
You didn't feel like you had to shit
immediately. You didn't like it.
Please answer my questions.
I have so many
because one time I had a medical finger in
my butt. Honestly, I felt damaged. Sure.
I was like, wow. He really was
rough with you. Well, he wasn't,
I mean it wasn't it rough for
damage or sore because he was too,
it was too rough. I mean, I,
I had a lot of thoughts
about anal after that.
Like not, not fun. Tender
felt tender. I was like, Ooh,
let me know if you never
had that, did you? Okay,
so you said that the finger
went in easily. Lot of Lube.
So he really, when I cleaned up back
there it was gunks so that's good. Yeah,
that was considerate of him.
Yeah.
So it went in easy and then you felt
when it got deeper as you're saying,
you felt the hook and he kind of
looked at in there. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Sort of thinking about that pegging class
we went to for Nikki. Who is your show?
Because we did a show. We did
Nikki Glaser show, not so safe.
And we went to a peg in class on the show.
Yeah. I was thinking about that. Like,
man, I remember how you guys were
like fucking these clay models. Yeah.
Oh my God. Even those like chapstick
sized ones, I go, man, I don't know.
I didn't,
I didn't think of anything feeling,
and I know I had a medical procedure.
I'm not trying to equate it with that,
but I'm just saying it was
so tender. I was like, Ooh,
you know the Butthole, it's,
it is real tender. Roney yeah. It's
just not for me personally, you know?
I don't condemn anybody that's into
it, but no, not at all. It's real,
real tender. Yeah. Okay, so now you
took a shit since then. Wait, wait,
wait. But did it hurt to shit? It
wasn't like that. No, no, no, no.
It was just like sensitive,
like, you know, like a muscle.
Yeah. Yeah. No one though. Like
those guys used to bang that.
Like they were just like,
oh,
rapid triage it out and they would wrap
or fire bang. We've got to be like, Whoa,
Whoa, whoa. Take it easy. You just
tell me about those guys. Like, like,
you know what I mean? It's called the
prison pound. Yeah. You love those, right?
Love prison pounding. Especially
when you start to dry out. Yeah.
It's like it takes too long and then yeah,
it just dry like a dry rub in there.
Kind of feels like that.
Here's the other part.
He goes,
well because of your digestive stuff and
we're not sure yet because you haven't
had the colonoscopy yet
and all this and that.
I want you to take this kit home,
shit into this plastic cup and then scoop
of pieces of the shit into these four
vials. Dude, I nearly
vomited this morning.
I also had, um, what's it called?
Performance anxiety.
I know you did.
Now don't you wish you
had just done the colon
brown, Brown John Coming up? Yeah,
I sent you wouldn't be punished and
have to do what you going about to talk
about doing. Well, I
still have it scheduled,
but I'm saying that had you done it prior,
you wouldn't have got,
you wouldn't go through what you
did today to have gone through that.
That was so disgusting. Let's talk
about it. So here's the thing too.
I,
I felt the nature calling and I went
up there and I sat down with a cup
underneath me and a plastic surgeon's
gloves to tell them the accouchement.
So you, you have a set of plastic
gloves, you've got a rubber gloves,
rubber gloves, you've got a,
basically a Dixie cap shit into shape.
And then you have several vials.
Yes.
Of each file has a lid. And
the, when you remove the lid,
there's a little shovel scooper and
it's for you to break up poop and put in
there.
And then there's,
and there's fluid in three
of them and nothing in one.
So I had two false alarms because
they're so worked up about it. Yeah.
I was like, I gotta do it because I also
have a busy day. It's not just like, Hey,
do this and then you're
done. It was do this, um,
then go to our house, we're moving
to, had to do something there,
come back here, bed,
go back there. Yeah. So
it was a lot of stuff.
What I'm saying is I, um,
man, when I finally got it
to come out, it was like,
it came out in, you know, in
one like blend chunk. Yeah.
It was kind of Mushy,
kind of stringy
and it was like in that, there
was something, I dunno man,
here's the thing.
I was fucking gagging at like,
what's into like, I've always wanted
to kind of pick it apart. I see. Like,
did you see pieces of stuff? Can I
tell you something? I realized too,
and I've said this before,
I can talk about the act
of shitting without it,
without a blink actual shit.
I'm not, I don't have, I can't
do it. I'm like, oh right,
you've said this before. You're
really not into it. Oh my God,
dude,
you're sitting there right there
with a cup of your own feces.
I have never done that. Chopping it
up. Oh, and here's the other part,
because I had to do those things.
I didn't had to put those containers
in a sealed bag in a third bag and keep
them in the frigerator. Cool. Right next
to our babies. No, I kept it in the,
in the drawer there's like a special
drawer we have under the fridge.
I put it in there. Good.
That is so gnarly, dude.
So you cut it out, but what was in your
poom asking? Did you find I saw stuff.
I don't want to bring it up to
him. Gagging. I was dry heaving.
I had tears running down my face. It
was really fucking disgusting. I really,
really hated it.
I can't even tell you.
Maybe one day when you've processed
it more, you can tell me what you saw.
It was bad. Just know that
it was bad. It was gross.
Yeah,
it was really bad and
that sounds terrible.
I dropped off.
I dropped off the heart monitor with,
so they're going to tell me what,
what happened overnight and then
I dropped off a bag of shit.
He's thorough.
Dr. I don't think I've ever heard of
anybody having to go through this much
stuff.
Even on the Dropbox,
I'll do another urine test because he
wanted to make sure my urine test was up
to par and was like, yeah, it's fine. They
ran the test. Right then bananas. Yeah.
Good though. That's what she want.
That's exactly what you want. So then,
okay, so that's drama.
Yeah. With the house.
And then I took LJ to the doctor today
for his checkup and he lost his shit.
I had to take blood from
his little heel today. No,
I had to sing twinkle,
twinkle little star for him to calm down.
I calmed them down. Yeah.
My voice is terrible,
but it's the only thing that stopped
him. It was so cute. Why didn't you sing
such a weird song? Yeah, I like it.
And then I found a love match for
our nanny or Guatemalan nanny. Um,
his name is Israel and he works in the
parking garage. Yeah. Where pediatrician.
He's real nice. Yeah. I really liked
his energy. I want to set them up.
Do you think he, uh, they're
both Guatemalan. Yeah. I
feel like it's a, it's a,
and they're both like super
sweet, you know? Yeah. Like I say,
sarcastic shit to both the nanny and to
people like Israel and they're just like
blank. Yeah. You know, like little
bit. How's it going? I'm like, well,
kids still alive today at all,
Dude, just remind you of it.
COMP, drought baller shit. No,
fuck them bombing the shit.
Fucking carbs are a fucking ball.
Yeah. Little bit had a little
similar. Same time. No,
no, no. This guy was much sweeter.
Okay. Like a nice Christian dude.
Fucking cops. Fucking Bob is a genius
about this. This sound like the guy
I always do. I hit on
me. It's fucking morning.
Fuck it was the enemy right there,
homie.
Lomi from the gs up.
Tracy Gang homies on value gang homie.
Fuck Lionel from waste sour me and
power gang homie still Bordeaux.
So Daniel's putting it.
That could have been the guy.
That's one of my favorite things of all
time is that those guys findings are
released. They're gangbangers. I
mean if the setup is true there,
there's a video. These two dudes
are like, you can hear him,
their total la Trobe say
like bought those and,
and they're like, I love gang
violence so much that they like,
it's like, uh, a hack premise
for a joke that they used to say.
Remember when they couldn't find
been loud and all these guys, man,
they should just get sent some crips
and bloods over there. You'll find him.
Shoot them. These guys were like, that's
how much we love it and killing. Yeah.
And they,
and then in the video they go crazy with
the machine gun and saying it's legit.
Yeah. I think that's a real thing. I've
always said it was hilarious, man. Me Too.
I like anything with gang bangers. Yeah.
Like Mexican ones. Butoh who radios,
you know, saying Homie la man. It's
solely homes. Did you see that?
It's sketch, people were passing
around the Cholo fitness. Yeah.
It was pretty funny. I got sent
that like 5,000 times. Yeah. Oh,
genes I guess sent that a lot too.
Anyways, so we have this bed that we, um,
the frame we should say the bed is Saatva,
which we've had are, you guys know, uh,
the bed is fun in the mattress is perfect,
but we ordered this bed and we got it.
It took months to get here. And
when it finally did. Oh my God,
it was,
it started squeaking and we got this bed.
It arrived in like June or something.
Oh my God. Is that it?
Is that our bed? No,
but it sounds
picture a picture too,
by the way.
You guys know we waited
a long, long, long time
to get a nice mattress,
which yes.
You know we can slap a
mattress and we waited a long,
long time to get this. This is a
really nice bed frame in. Yeah.
Like we spent, you know,
decent money on this for sure.
We didn't have a bed frame.
Yeah. For years. No bed frame.
Just a bad,
just the mattress.
I used to sleep with a bachelors on the
floor and then at one point we got just
one step up, which was just, what
is it? Just a box for rail? Yeah.
Block Saatva set it up there. Like
do you have a, a frame? I go, no.
And they set up, they love,
it's what solve it right.
Gave us so then when we move we're like,
why don't we get a proper look? Adults.
Yeah. Like and with a nice
headboard, you know? Yeah.
And we went to a really nice
store and we did it. We're like,
we're buying this really nice bed frame.
It's like an investment by the way.
We bought it, let's say in
February. And they were like,
it's going to be delivered March 1st
and then write it to her at the end of
February. They go, it's not ready. And we
go, okay, well you know it's been a month,
but how much longer? We think in
April. Yeah. Oh, another month. Yeah.
Then they just didn't call back.
Do you remember that? They look,
of course I played then anyways.
Then they were like, okay,
you know when we complain
where you're getting the bed,
the guys came out and set it up and
day one like you lay on the bed.
Okay.
But I think we, a couple things. We had a
newborn baby. Yes. And we also were like,
it's new. Like maybe this is
maybe settling. Yes. Yeah, yeah.
And Man,
it's,
it felt like it got worse.
Yeah. I got white worker and
then I would any movement,
any movement.
And you and I get up to pee in the
night five times between the two of us.
So every time one of us gets up it's
like the loudest, it's a nice sound.
Okay.
The frame. That's what you do here
at two o'clock in the morning. Yeah.
And then the person leaves
and makes you think,
oh are you talking about
a hundred year old bed?
I know three or four month
old bit and they made it,
it was one of those like
custom. Yeah, bed frames.
Like it wasn't just some pos. No. Anyways,
I started to get desperate.
You know when you,
when you have the thought of you
picture them saying fuck you,
you bought it. Yeah. Yeah. I used to
have, I would have those in my mind.
I know you were really fired up like
to a point where I was kind of worried
because you are ready. We're convinced
that they weren't going to fix it. Yeah.
And you were like, you call, okay,
you call a UGL it cause I'm going
to get too angry. And I was like,
all right babe. Like I know when you're
fired up about something. Yeah. I'm like,
all right, I'll fucking call them. And
they were totally sweet about yeah.
Oh my can of course send us a
recording of the squeak and then from,
it's like protocol for them and
then we can send somebody out.
They sent somebody out within 48
hours. Yeah, but you were on your last,
like he was one of those things where
you would love town and you're like,
could you fix the bed please this
week? And I'm like, yeah, sure.
On top of everything else that's going on,
the kid being sick or you know,
whatever. I'm going to make
sure. So we finally fixed it.
Finally Heimaey came. Was
that today? Yeah. Hi. May
came. And so what did he say?
Why has it been so shitty?
He said the washers were the wrong ones.
Cool.
Certain things weren't done
tightly and you know, he took,
we took the mattress off together,
then the box spring and then he
just worked with like the core,
like the rails and he said,
you know,
Ron washers here and uh,
tightened everything up. Boom.
Yeah. Cause I sat on, it was great.
Oh my God. I know it's bright.
It's really been disruptive. I think it's
been psychological torture. Yeah, it is.
It is. Because we wake up every time
one of us mood any movement. Eh,
eh. I mean you should be able
to move without. Amen. Yeah.
It was so bad.
It's so weird that we did wait so long,
so long.
We just adapted to it.
A couple of idiots.
It's horrible every day.
It is one of those things
where as as humans you just,
you're so adaptable. Yeah,
yeah, of course wrong. And then
you're like, well, just live.
We'll just live around this misery
and were really into that. Oh yeah.
That's the bad.
That makes noise.
Okay.
You realize how long we dealt with at
that level. No, I mean it's really,
it's pretty a long time.
It's like having one phone charger in the
house half a year. We've been sleeping
like that
wrong with us. When you're
like, we can buy phone chargers,
like we can have them in every room.
Like, Oh yeah, that's why like 10 of them.
Why do I suffer? And it's like
such an easy fix. Did they,
they didn't even charge us to
fix the bed, right? Uh, no. Yeah,
I gave the guys from scratch that we're
doing such a good, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I suffer so much sometimes.
Yeah. Needlessly.
God. Do you want to hear a
crazy accent or see a crazy,
a porn clip that's not
hardcore? Sure. Which one?
Porn or ag accent. I mean, you know,
[inaudible] stone,
Bondo,
turn what's available and stuff
like me and a blind competition
and they made arrangements.
They were calling us.
One of my favorite thing from the top
of this is that he's making a challenge
video and not lowering the
audio in the background. Well,
you get to hear him,
right.
But in any break you get to hear
loud television in the background.
And I think the lighting is from the
television. Yes. It looks like. Yes.
So he just has a TV room and rambling,
senseless nonsense.
I heard him say any man wants to fight me,
which is, it's a pretty
bold, yeah. Challenge. Right?
I feel like he and the deck hand
guy, yeah. Would be a good man.
He might be the Irish version
of the deck hand. It might be,
although I feel like this guy
is less of a piece of shit.
Even watching somebody make a,
I'll fight anybody video.
I still feel like he's less of a
piece of shit. Sure. In the deck hand,
he's got his life together a bit more.
He has an apartment in doors, right?
That we know about it. That's
true. He does live inside. Yeah.
I don't, boy any moms
there. Is that right?
[inaudible] look at me.
Look at me.
I'm strong demos.
Amy, what's up with his mouth?
He needs a, what is it called?
The million dollar smile.
Why?
Why his teeth like that? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. He looks really in bread too.
Oh boy. Yo, this kid like, oh boy.
He said he's nine and a half stone.
Nine and a half stone. Yeah. Yeah.
[inaudible]
the, he's missing a title. I know. I'm
trying to, I'm trying to absorb it.
I'm trying to understand. I'm trying to
do the math on nine and a half stone.
I know what it is that minus
the teeth. Wait. Uh, uh,
God dammit.
He weighs what?
Jesus.
What is it? Nine and a half. Nine and
a half stone. I forget what the fuck.
And you know in your kilometers
you for Rainer's nine stone.
What? How could that be right?
Nine stones. 126 pounds.
That's right. He would seem
to be that much half. I Dunno.
I Dunno. How much do boys that
age way? What does he like?
30 10 stone is 140 I guess that's what
made me, he's like 130 pounds. All right,
man. Was that few teeth?
That's fucking nuts.
That's really nuts. Chiclets that
are left are black. They're not good.
Smoking and drinking every
day. God, this could be,
this could makes me scared
to go to Dublin, man. Jesus.
Is that how your 13 year olds are?
I don't know where he's at. Oh yeah,
they're all they do is drink a, what
is it? Guinness? Is that Ireland?
Yeah, of course. Yeah. I
love Dennis. Of course,
when it's fresh, like in the UK,
not the bullshit we have here.
I like the bullshit here in the UK. It's
even better. It's not shit goes down man.
It goes down easy. Yeah. Yup, Yup.
I like that. I like harp logger.
That's my jam. Yeah. And
the CIDER Strongbow. Hmm.
Huh? And me brother. I heard that part.
You got a brother in the video.
What's duffer too?
It says that on his sweatshirt.
Don't talk.
It kinda looks like like
a hardcore lesbian woman,
right? Yes. Yeah.
Like if this person was like I'm a
woman, I'd be like, yeah. All right.
Now his pronouns all over the place.
Maybe that's what's going on.
Maybe the teeth are, as part of this
trend, there's binary shift. You know,
maybe his pronoun is a
dent.
Dental tenders.
There's a miracle smile.
Do you think we could
send him one in Ireland?
Why does his brother up so many teeth?
Oh, the shipping and handling on that.
It's got to be, you know,
cause we bought a pair of,
they haven't arrived yet of
the million dollar smile.
The thing itself was what? $12? No,
49 nine shipping was 1399 right.
Which is his badge as the
product. Shipping and handling
was a dollar less. Yeah,
it was total. It's a total, totally
ripping poor people off on the shipping.
These people don't even have teeth.
I know. Hey for the fucking box.
No
bullying
leaving boy a con
bike.
Make a long story short prison. Yeah.
[inaudible] box.
No,
we got a close up of that
man. Oh No. Black and Brown.
He's too young for that.
It was he in prison.
It sounds like my ears are
working so good today. I mean,
normally this just flows out of me.
So I'm about being in prison.
Like
I feel like this is his version of,
you know what I'm saying? Listen to me.
Look at me. Listen to me. Look at me.
Yeah.
Is fucking, oh my fucking
God dude. He's annoying me.
Like the retard fucking redneck guy.
Yeah.
A blue band. Redeem
himself. Damn. Good job.
Live in God.
Jesus.
Oh bummer. Yeah, she's, yeah.
Was this a cheer you up?
That's fine.
You answered
it.
So this is a puppet foreign.
Oh, that's a puppet.
She actually had sex with the puppet
genre cause they're incredible.
This puppet has, it looks
like Aaliyah. Oh my God. No,
that's not aliyah.
So disrespectful
that her, Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
So she that he has a puppet painter.
She just has sex with the puppy.
She going to have sex with a puppet
though. I mean is they have a dildo.
Oh God. Why don't you just
rides it like it's a real
bit.
She has to below the puppet boy.
Oh boy. Yeah. No, for real. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. And this woman did this. Yeah, she's
cute though. She could have had a normal,
I'm sure she does do regular stuff, I'm
sure. But yeah, this time they were like,
here's an extra 60 bucks for a pub it.
But as far as pouring goes,
this is probably one of the more
desirable gigs or you're right.
I mean there's no STDs. There's
no common. Your face. All right.
It's not like blowing the Wu Tang clan.
Oof All nine oh nine I think about that
since we talked about that on the last
episode. Yeah. I keep thinking
about it man. Like yeah,
cause you chosen a worst band for that.
That isn't the worst group. What are
they called? What is it? What does a rap,
it's just funny to say like group band.
I'm like,
what are their rap band, right? Yeah. I
mean there, there are 80 years old. Yeah.
Another wrap group. Yeah, there's
gotta be better. What a crazy band
somebody wrote in like Hanson's three
boys. I thought Hanson was two boys.
I both, I also said one direction
that isn't that for or was for
budget.
People wrote in about the a PSA
already sending in new length.
They're like,
dude,
those aren't even the hardcore
homos are more hardcore.
It's are we going to see them or, oh
yeah. I mean, all right here. Let's see.
Um, I love when they go. Like this one
came in right now this is for Tommy bonds.
I know he'll get a kick out of
it. No. Yeah, it happens. Yeah.
Forget. Excited. Click
send. Okay. What's this one?
No real good job on your picture please.
She spilled my coffee.
I'm sorry sir.
You're fucking bitch.
I got like that.
You wouldn't get away with it here.
You shouldn't get away with it at home.
Yeah.
That is not a p as not a cool PSA.
What country was that? That
wasn't America. Thanks Sean.
Thanks dude. Was a real fucking
bummer. Whoa. That was terrible.
The air that you fucking bitch. Oh yeah.
It's definitely on America then here.
But he had an American accent.
Canadia what'd be like?
Don't you wouldn't do this egg.
Yeah. Do it your waitress. Huh?
That one's real crazy. I guess. You
know what? Maybe it is Canadian Canada.
I think they actually give a shit about
people and things like this. Right?
Okay.
[inaudible] in a terrible accident.
[inaudible]
Whoa,
man.
Uh,
there's not fucking around. No, no, no. I
think you're definitely right about that.
Wow. I was terrifying. Oof.
It could have prevented that.
She was a nice young lady.
That was pretty terrible,
but you fucking bitch and he beat the
shit out of her for that will be cool. No,
that's just like, uh,
I've never, I would never,
we've never done that to a waitress.
Fuck man. I'm, you've wanted to do that
to a waitress. No. Come on.
They have a a little,
you mentioned retard porn.
That's what it says.
Being a groundskeeper for the frat
houses can be a pain in the ass,
but there are a few things that keep me
here. One is that nobody fucks with me.
The powers to be,
let me do my own thing.
As long as the yards are kept
up and there are no problems,
there should be obvious.
There is more barely legal twat on
campus anywhere else in the city. Boy,
Hey God, I enjoy looking
at fresh, young snatch.
Just particular to house was put on my
list last month and this was the first
time that had a chance to work
here or the narratives middle.
I can't believe they're still thinks
I'm a fucking retard. What an insult.
There you go.
Because
yeah,
so he's pretending to be
sure,
sure.
I can carry anything.
I couldn't help but wonder if why this
beanie cut was talking to me like a moron.
I understand.
My name's Chris.
I can't believe this.
Duncan
thinks I'm a fucking retard.
What an insult because I started a little,
there's no reason to
think that I'm an idiot.
I'm going straight in this dunk cut out.
And I remembered that I was wearing a
shirt that had writing on front special
Olympiads before. I could
say a word. She hugs me.
My Dick instantly got hard.
I thought you'd feel it.
I thought of playing a retard.
It was going to get me laid.
I'm all for it.
This is really good research.
Seriously. What's your name? Billy.
Billy. Yes. Pretty good.
Yeah, it's pretty funny.
It's quite the setup too. Yeah, I
do too. So many like quick to the,
you know, right to the action,
but this is, yeah. You know,
build some humor and excitement around it.
It's a story. Yeah. Really get into it.
Yeah. Elaborate story. Yeah. Yeah.
It's pretty good. And sweet.
Keep going or no, I mean,
I feel like I know where it's going.
What do you think's going to happen next?
Okay.
What are you,
where are you guys?
I don't understand how you know where
it's going because I haven't even watched
it yet.
Where's it going?
Yeah.
Um, I think the more, do you think
he'll stay retarded for the sec?
Well,
what's the,
what's the tagline to the points
now and here? We're all in one.
So he finishes and he goes,
Bam. I don't know how. Okay.
Like, what's his fetish?
And he's like, ah, no,
I'm not retarded. Who's retarded? No,
he said if I was going to
make so aggressive and fast
and this like,
she via founded upon it.
Well, he's like done like write books,
so I don't know. Revenge to make it work.
Yeah.
Um, she's really not
pretty. You're Sloan now
attractive. Um, well, what are
they doing? Can you describe it?
Because I'm watching it.
He's alone. Jerking off.
Well, I figured the trick was
not dead, too embarrassed at all.
So then I looked at who cries like
stupid. Like he kept on Jack. Yeah.
Can BP her? Let's see. He's
quiet. Yeah. So she's, she's
being nice to him.
I figure I better make my plan now
because she was looking at my cock like it
was her last meal,
so I took her hand and grand hat.
This is so fucking long. Right. All right.
Get to it. Yeah. Now it's, you can
hear the music. They're doing it.
The retired style. Well, not retarded.
He's really a munching on her stuff,
but I kind of want to see what year.
Just wanted to see
the grand finale.
What's the,
and also I wanted to see if he
was going to be retarded, right?
Or is he going to tell her the truth?
Like, yeah. Higher Iq than you bitch.
Yeah.
That's what I retards,
it's gotta be a finale.
MMM.
No. Oh, here we go. I
think we're getting close.
Yeah. Big retarded finale.
The big fake retarded valley.
It's a really underwhelming
performance, by the way. What?
It looks like two people
fairly like missionary,
but barely really moving.
You know, it's not soft core.
No, no, no, no. It's not,
but it's like real bland.
Okay,
here you go.
Ah,
who's retarded?
Okay.
Ah,
no line. Nothing. I didn't
even think this through
a lot of acne.
Oh,
they really missed out a golden
opportunity here and the punchline.
Nothing.
I was starting to get a little worried
he was putting on her clothes so she was
getting real quiet.
Has it beginning to think that maybe
the Jig was up and she was pissed.
I figured what the Hell is that pussy
was definitely worth every trouble.
He kind of promised me that.
You won't tell anyone,
Huh?
Christy can get in a lot of trouble for
taking advantage of this special person.
Okay, Miss Christy, I promise.
Oh Damn. Yeah they could really,
that was it.
Like that was such a
blessing that we just got
one over on the slow girl
man. He should have been like,
yeah, no retarded. You dumb
bitch. Stupid Bitch. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. You fucked a
pretend retard. Oh my God.
And somebody else will good. We got a lot
of emails about this. This is my fault,
but I'm sorry if the,
uh,
if us dumping the back catalog ruined
your data plan B in your storage, right.
You guys, we explained in the last
episode, but then we got so much,
we just did it to,
to be nice and to give out the entire
back catalog to you guys because we get
asked a lot for it. Yeah. And I, and we
did, we always are like, oh, one day,
any other day we just said
let's just do it. And um,
I insisted and then, I mean, people have
been writing a lot like, oh, thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Uh,
but wanting to to find these,
but I definitely got a bunch of like,
what in the fuck?
Like my phone shut off.
Um,
anyways, really sorry if, uh, if it,
you know, fucked up your storage
and everything but a hope.
Hope you do like having access to
all the back catalogs in eight hours.
We had over 1.5 million
down crazy. Um, yeah,
because we'd done that like once before,
a million years ago.
It was way before the show took off.
Yeah. And it didn't have the impact,
so we did not know. I
didn't know. Sorry guys.
Um, anyways, people
wrote more farts please.
This eight email just came in from mason.
Okay.
I am a longtime mommy recently
looking through your amendment Mama.
So decided to listen to episode
one 93 with cousin Janette.
I'm glad you mentioned that. Undoubtedly
one of your finest mama sows. Uh,
I had an epiphany as I was listening.
I had an epiphany where
have all the parts gone.
I listen every week and
did not notice until now.
There has been a real fart
drought at your mom's house.
I do not know what the
reasoning behind this is,
but I think I speak for a lot of
mommies. When I say, come on, you guys,
show me how those big tits fart.
With that being said,
I still love the show immensely.
A door, the main mommy's,
but seriously more fart please.
A Mason from Charlotte. I saw Tom, uh,
on the 15th.
Now does he mean that we aren't farting
or that we don't play enough farts?
I think it's a combination of the two.
It's really been a fart decline.
And I will say the reason that our farts
tapered off is because our microphones,
we used to hold them in our hands and then
we upgraded the studio. We've got the,
and now we do these.
And it's really hard to fart into these
microphones cause there's an arm, right?
Oh, what is that? And
you'd have to uh, Jeez.
I think you're, whoa.
Uh, um, all right. Yeah,
we're good. Uh, you're answering
the question for them though.
What do you mean get far mix?
Just put mics on.
That's really good. And we can get them
professional grade like these [inaudible]
yeah. And then what happens is
you mute them and I let you know,
like that's your fart. So whenever
you have one you just unmute it.
It's a really good idea. I mean, it really
get, and guess what happened as we're,
as we're talking about this,
sure.
As we're having this convert sation the
king has returned from his long Brown
cation. No. And surprisingly enough,
he's still ripping some damn farts.
Wow. Well look, can we see, can we see it?
I mean,
he's back.
Our great leader
an apartment.
Whoa.
It's still doing his thing and
stuff like that. That's his. Wow.
Wow.
Yeah.
Sorry. You know, I feel like
it's been so long. It feels like
the first time, you know?
Yeah. Nice. Whole there. Ooh,
Jesus.
Oof Man.
I missed him so much.
Now this is a,
an upgrade because when we more
king parts around apartment,
that's the title of the video course.
The first time we found him he was
in his parents' basement. Yeah.
And now he's got his own place,
which is great.
There's been other kitchens and other
rooms though. I feel like he's moved.
Maybe he's the Kinda guy that can't hold
down a job long and therefore we lose a
lot, you know? No, kind of
feels like that to me. Uh,
surely none really farting a lot though.
I like the whole,
yeah, it looks good. Ooh. That
felt like that could go wrong.
That could go south real quick.
His guts. Sure. A shrink.
Yeah.
Si.
What do you think doctor would say to him?
I was just thinking that he would have to
go through his shit with his own hands.
Now, a lot of people over the years have
written to us and say that ass rappers a
fraud and that he'll pump
his rectum full of air. Yeah.
I don't see how that's Po.
How can you fart for five?
Whole consecutive meant there are no
edits. There are edits. Oh, and this one,
there is a lot on watching right now and
it's like, like three fights in a row.
Let's see. Okay, let's see.
Rod, he's tiny. Assassinated. Okay.
Yeah, it's all the third or fourth.
But do you think he's a fraud? No,
man. I mean he's, he's dedicated.
That's a really impressive car.
That was one.
Sounds like, I mean that is a
lot of air coming out, so yeah.
Well,
I mean you either have to be
consuming constantly to keep that out,
which he likes to consume is a
gluttonous slob or whatever. Yeah.
Harry and gross letting a
Slob. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
he is the only,
the only person who has not come
on your mom's house after us.
We're sorry doing him. He did give a
shout out to us though. He did. No,
he didn't say it. If you, when he
had his youtube channel, he said,
it said in the video description,
shout out to your mom's house. Oh cool.
So he gave us some props. It was a tip of
the cap. That's a good tip of the panty.
That was the most he would do. He did not
want any exposure. So interesting. And,
and I, we either went on
over there. Yeah. And we,
we talked about him and they were an yeah,
we did a profile and show Joe.
And even with all that,
after we got back from that, we
were like, now let's try to get,
and he was unresponsive.
We asked people,
we found out his contact info because
it was posted, I think on live league.
We offered him money. Yeah. We
offered him money and hey dude,
we'll pay you whatever art because I love
it. Yeah. The love of the game. Yeah.
It really is. You can't be bought.
He doesn't want the, the glory.
That's how he's a purist. You respect
him for that. He's a purist. Yeah.
He doesn't show his face as much anymore.
If you'll notice,
it's just the panties.
And the
no, he still shows. It
turns back and yeah,
but it's not really now.
Look,
have a look what's coming up here though.
Your favorite look out brown.
Oh my God. But then I'm up is
my favorite. It's the best.
Yeah.
How this makes me so sad.
This is going well and he used
to do the double thumbs up.
It's been a really great,
yeah.
Snappy. Oh, that's a good one.
I got to tell you.
That looks familiar to me. I think
this might be old footage. No,
these might be old fart. Yeah. Yeah.
No, no. I don't recognize this room.
What's on the walls? What do you think
that is? Sure. A band that's a weird,
it doesn't fit him
house.
Love
that one. That the Coi on my
stomach one oopsies. Yeah,
very clear and gross. Oh, he is
more farts around my apartment.
Thumbs up if you want
more apartment farts.
Let's see.
Of course we want more apartment for it
was kind of dumb question is just do it.
Just give us what the people want.
He's a construction worker.
How do you know? Says it on the
site. What site, but on Youtube,
on his profile says,
my gluttony has become a hobby of mine.
I work as a construction worker and I
keep my gluttony a secret from my family.
Oh,
I'm gaining for all my subscribers and
love scarfing down tons of fattening and
lard, gross food and garbage to
pack in my growing Harry Beer Gut,
my goal is to reach 300 pounds
with the help of my fans. Okay.
So that makes sense.
He wants to remain anonymous.
Never written that much before though.
No, it doesn't sound like him. You know,
the thing about him is he does have this
Banksy quality where it's cause there's
all these,
cause he's been kicked off of Youtube
and lively because so many times.
And I always wonder if somebody,
just the videos, you know,
ripping them and then saying that
they're him. He's so mysterious.
That writing that you just read,
that's not ass rapper voice.
That's just not him.
I don't believe it.
And then this is good.
Like this is more
vast editing. Yeah.
There's an effect. Yes.
Edit.
And it's this like a flashback the way
that they're editing it. Yeah, this is,
this is an old wise, this is not him.
This is in my mind. You're supporting
her staff are really advanced editing.
This is six
man.
And smashing it with some beer or
the audio is right with it.
Steve's babies was fucking
loads of Manet's, Huh?
Yeah.
Feel like it's too advanced. You know. Um,
I remember what he did this thing that
was really gross where he used to sit on
food. I know. I didn't like hard
on it and then eat it. Yeah.
That was like really,
really into now this look,
according to this one,
he would fart on like eggs and need them.
So gross.
So gnarly.
Quietly farting around my apartment
is the name of one quiet. Wow.
That does look recent. Then quality video.
New panties. Yeah. This one's
new. I am fascinated by him.
Of course. Is the most intriguing
person from your mom's house.
That's real low quality. Yeah. This
is new. This is a new apartment.
I believe that he works construction.
Yeah.
On the ladder. Set up.
Climbing the ladder.
I like his set up, so that's my favorite.
The storylines. He's a lunatic man.
Yup. Yup. Um,
that's funny that that came back as we
read the other emails that it wasn't a
setup man. Isn't that serendipitous? Yeah.
Isn't that interesting how the
universe wants you to hear those farts?
Really does. Where are the farts? Here?
They are asking. You shall receive.
[inaudible] I got a pack.
I know.
I'm so tired of what we were up with
so early with Lj. Yeah. Who is it by?
Cracking. Ah. All right, let's go.
I'm going to eat some Turkey sausage.
All right. I'm going to go to bed.
All right. Thanks for listening guys.
Let me love you mommy. Your mom's house,
podcast.com Si.
Yo and I see a smelling new
lane or smell you later.
[inaudible]
you don't say same.
Same,
right?
You know what I'm saying?
Mom. Mom, mom.
Nope. That same friend check soon. US.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the mayor of know what I'm saying
like this.
Please forgive me.
You don't say the same. Oh, la La proper.
Right
from spot
to
anyone on this fence.